Hello Freak bitches.
Yeah.
Most people think Oj did.
It does a few people that think like I heard the crazy ones like,
oh,
j son did it or something like that.
I'm like,
why I'm so balls deep in the Oj stuff.
Anything he does,
I watch it.
But like I said,
my brother went,
God,
I Went,
I wish I really knew the truth about o j and j my brother looks at me goes,
are you shitting me?
Like,
we all know the truth,
man.
But people put all these different stories out there where you're like,
God,
maybe he didn't do it,
but I just want to know for a fact like that.
Like what?
How did it really go down?
Do you think he's ever going to come out and be like,
listen,
no,
I don't think he did.
I don't think he necessarily remembers anymore.
You think it was just in a frenzy?
I think it's entirely possible that he's a sociopath and a narcissist with brain
trauma.
Yeah.
Trauma.
And I think that a lot of times narcissists and sociopaths like to that degree,
like he's just charming the world.
Hey,
I'm Oj Simpson.
I'm a good guy.
I've always been a good guy.
I basically the conflict free life.
Yeah.
I just want to go be with my family.
Got sounds like a man.
He's got a weird thing going on man.
Like he's trying to paint this image all day long of him being a good guy.
Meanwhile he's got these demons and knows dad was gay and I said that's why he
would beat like a lot like you so upset about that.
See,
I don't trust that guy,
but when he gave that,
uh,
yeah,
he's like snapped at the judge.
Yeah.
Like it was super weird and you definitely shouldn't do that when you're trying
to get what he got upset about something that I'm on something.
He's like,
I said I wasn't there or something like that.
Yeah,
yeah.
I forget what it was,
but like that Las Vegas Room definitely didn't handle it well.
Who?
Look man,
when you're a man and you're locked up with other men,
you know,
as prisoners all day long forever.
It's just,
it's a horrific existence.
It's amazing that he was able to get through it at all and then still pull off
that kind of charm and not can only do slide.
Yeah.
They said he was killing it in the,
like he was the prime example of a,
of a prisoner and it was like he started organizing church groups and like
feeding everyone's lunches and like,
he was cool.
Wow.
Well find meaning in that shit.
I wonder if you'd like,
has like a deep what's going on?
Chloe's dad.
Yeah.
A lot of people think he's closed.
That get the fuck Outta here.
What?
Chloe's not half black.
Uh,
well they just don't love black guys.
They is that what it is?
Hmm.
Some people do both.
And you know,
Oj was super close with strong rumour Claudette.
She had strong rumor.
That strong rumor.
No one be surprised.
Uh,
I would,
well,
my point was like what kind of memory of the event?
Okay.
We both agree he did it right.
So if he did it,
what kind of memory does he have?
Do you,
do you remember sticking the knife in them?
[inaudible] I remember that traumatic event or I wonder,
I wonder,
I wonder if you're a sociopath and I wonder if you've been telling people for
all these years that you're innocent.
[inaudible] trying to find the real killer.
I'm trying to get out and find the real killer.
Everyone's all not once did he bring up the real killer.
I'm trying to find my wife's killer.
The reason why,
I mean,
he never said that during like any of the parole thing when he can't get out.
Oh No,
not on my wife's killer.
Yeah.
Never on this.
Someone killed my wife.
That ship's sailed was not me.
I'm being tried for it.
I'm being unjustly accused.
He does say that the case that I lost,
he came out with a book.
If I did it.
Yeah,
he was going to,
but he didn't release that book.
I thought he did know all the proceeds went to the,
the goal.
No.
Um,
I believe,
I'm pretty sure that the publishing company backed out of that price.
Smart on their part.
Yeah.
You can't do that,
dude.
Will you have him on the podcast?
Oh,
I don't know if he would do it,
but if he did do it.
Yeah,
I have mine.
Yeah.
Right.
Yeah,
I'd have done mine.
I did it
straight up.
IDF is right.
It's hidden right there.
Remember?
That's what they did.
Oh,
that's right.
If I did it in the eye now on Amazon by Oj Simpson.
Jesus Christ.
That's,
that's still,
I thought they pulled that confessions of the killer in all caps.
Oh,
that there Goldman and Kim Goldman.
Nick.
That's how it happened.
They had to,
they're,
they're getting all the money,
all the money,
but in did he really?
Right.
The full story and what are the rights to them?
Yeah,
because double jeopardy,
right.
Make money off the crime is sort of what it is.
How much money do,
and also they have a civil case against him.
How much money do you think he made off that book?
Got You.
Don't make that much money off books unless you're just fucking,
you do feel like Bill O'reilly,
j k Rawlins or some shit.
Yeah.
If you're writing books like old people read by a lot of books.
If I did it,
we kind of know how you do it.
If he did it,
if I need to read the two knife,
both of them go to Chicago,
called the lawyers come back,
come back,
act dumb.
Rinse Kardashian helps me out.
Rinse,
repeat.
Does it say how many books,
how many books they sold?
I got to think it was not much.
I don't even know it was out and I'm all about this.
He got some sort of crazy settlement.
Right?
It was like a $35 million settlement or something.
33 million.
But how much has he been paid?
I used to know is um,
um,
Ron Goldman sister.
Really?
Yeah.
How'd you know her?
She worked,
um,
on something that I did for,
she was very nice.
Very cool check.
Brian ran into the dad in Phoenix selling men's shirts.
Flight.
What's the big paws nuns?
I was trying to think what his cell selling,
but I remember selling like men's golf shirts or some shit.
Like the struggle is real for Ron Goldman,
you know,
like game over,
you lose a child and it goes down like that.
Just to just hard believe that that guy is now going to get out.
What do you do?
I mean you only got so certain amount of time left on this planet.
I,
I'd probably get a hand.
I'd probably,
yeah,
Hammer,
but it's gonna be tough to get Oj still pretty athletic and black.
So I would,
I'd probably get a gun and when he gets out,
drive down to Florida or if he comes back to Brentwood skin,
make it super easy on you and probably shoot him.
Could be headed to reality TV.
And when I called,
Oh my God,
I've watched that documentary about them comply.
I completely forgot about all the weird stuff he was doing before he did go to
jail show in Vegas where you had,
I didn't even know about it.
Seeing it on the documentary shows everything I did to wrap.
Yeah.
You gotta rap still rap after he murdered his wife.
Oh yes.
Before,
right before he went to jail and like 2005 or six innocent.
I'm innocent.
He was like the guys,
of course.
Yeah.
I'm innocent.
[inaudible] good.
We're going to get pulled off of youtube for the Oj Simpson.
No Way.
Look at this.
Oh my God.
Wait a minute.
We got to play this.
Let's,
let's ride.
Let's ride this.
Give us some fine.
Oh my God.
These girls
got white face
titties out.
This a real music video.
America's most wanted.
Wow.
This is crazy.
He's dressed up like Elvis.
I can't believe this is real.
Okay.
Looks those titties.
Gimme some volume here.
People hear this,
right?
People on Youtube are Hannis.
No.
Oh,
I don't know.
That'll get taken down problem.
Now if few play just the audio.
No Way.
Oj Simpson get juiced.
What year did this happen?
Like 2004 2005
yeah.
This is insane.
It's all these girls taking their pants off.
Yeah.
Can you give us doing prank show and you got juice with the tag line?
Oh my God.
He did it.
He did a fucking prank show after he murdered two people.
He's got a midget on his lap.
This is insane.
I can't believe it.
I've seen this.
Oh my God.
All you player haters.
Get on your knees and get some of these,
and then grabbed his crotch.
He said,
these nuts,
this is crazy.
And you,
and you got to think,
is this 2005 is that what you said?
So he's gotta be like 60 years old when this is happening.
Damn.
It only has 15,000
views on youtube.
Check in and in a couple of days
we just helps the juice.
Don't think people knew about that.
Another reason he needs to come on the Goddamn podcast.
Yeah.
Maybe to him.
Come on dressed like Elvis again.
No,
no.
Maybe we'll come on just as white face.
God Damn.
This is nuts.
He's a terrible person.
Yeah.
I wonder if he was like,
look,
I really,
I make money and so on through this idea at him.
Look at them with a do ragging.
Yeah.
Don't piss them off though.
Very strange.
So you did a Bingo at like a
old people home or something.
Oh my gosh.
Struggle is real.
This is so strange.
I can't believe this.
It was rap song where it's like it's hard in the streets in La.
That is true.
Yeah.
He was like a legit wrap flung though.
This is the remix.
Jamie.
He's got a good point.
Both of them are good.
We don't need to watch anymore on a terrible person.
I wonder what he's,
I mean,
I feel like a guy like that probably like would do anything.
It's like these get,
we've got to figure out some way to do and who's going to be working with them?
You're not going to get like the top minds of Hollywood.
Fuck no,
no one's still him.
I mean,
he might pop up on some reality show,
but dude,
a matching those hoes,
they were saying he was getting more women than ever when he got out,
when he was out of trial,
they still went to Florida and was just dicking girls down now,
like resell,
killing it.
What ties got out?
What type of sites
co
chicks are hooking up with Oj right now?
Skanks
okay.
[inaudible].